good afternoon everybody if we can if we
can get started
I'm Gary Tomlinson
the director of the Whitney Humanities
Center I said said that to most of you
yesterday afternoon welcome back for the
second of david Shulman's finzi-continis
yesterday's was entitled the kind of the
city of copper from the Thousand and One
Nights and david spun around an amazing
intricate eerie and even comical story
his own eloquent gripping tale weaving
together threads from many languages
many centuries three continents today's
lecture is entitled from Arabic to Tamil
two mimosas of Oliver lakhs mimosas is a
film we screened yesterday before his
lecture in talking with David this
morning I learned that it was a chance
viewing of the film that set him on the
path we've been hearing about the path
that has taken us round about him
through the city of copper with its
ghosts its genies and most memorably
it's edible mermaids I remarked on the
serendipity of this film screening and
David immediately asked but do you know
the etymology of that word serendipity
no I thought epical David Schulman
question I had begun to learn I said no
I've never I'd never thought of it I
realized it comes he said from an old
Persian story the three princes of
Serendip and Saladin was the Arabic name
for Sri Lanka an island that in old
Arabic navigational lore could only be
come upon by accident just like the city
of copper serendipity links then Sri
Lanka the city of copper the Thousand
and One Nights
Arabic Tamil the film David's project as
a whole and probably all truly
interesting scholarly endeavors but the
three princes of Serendip the story goes
traveled the world making discoveries by
accident and sagacity of things they
were not in quest of serendipity was not
for them a question of accidents alone
but of knowledge learning and wisdom so
it is with David's project we had a
sense yesterday of an extraordinary mind
at work of prodigious learning and of
the consummate storytelling that can
take shape in their presence
the first lecture left us on the edges
of our seats let's get on to the second
please join me again in welcoming David
Shulman to the podium
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Thank You Kerry hello everybody so
I'm assuming that you have some
knowledge of the story I am going to try
to offer a kind of exploitation of what
I think is the real intellectual driving
force of this story I'm speaking about
this mysterious City of the Dead the
city of copper madinat and ojas which is
hidden somewhere in the unknowable
reaches of the Libyan desert or possibly
in the Moroccan Sahara or somewhere on
the road to India a city that has no
gates or doors that can be opened from
outside the one of the locked gates can
be unlocked from the inside if you can
get inside and if you can then decipher
the strange inscription engraved on a
copper horseman who was standing there
and on our way to the city we heard
about the mysterious Lord of that gate
that has no gatekeeper Safiye built baba
la vie lisen loveable web and I argued
at the end of yesterday's talk that this
is a story not so much about death and
the unthinkable mystery of dying as it
is about time or rather times in the
plural about the incompatible temporal
rhythms that taken together comprise the
magic of this bizarre city I don't want
to dispel the magic only perhaps to
deepen it a little by speaking about
time the way the Muslim philosophers and
free thinkers of the 9th and 10th and
11th centuries understood it let me say
again that I think our story emerged at
least in part out of that matrix the
matrix of those discussions and that it
is in its own lyrical way a continuation
of them the primary axis of contention
runs between
[Music]
abdelbaki al-razi i mentioned it
yesterday and his is my Ely opponent so
here are two names I would like you to
try to remember I'm del Bakr Muhammad
ibn Zakaria arrazi I remember that the
reason you need to know the whole name
is because Rossi means that he came from
the city of Rai that's today part of
Tehran and there were a lot of people
came from Roy was a major Centre in
those centuries so there are many are
Aziz but the one I want to focus on is
this abdel baccarat Razi he lived from
854 to 925 he was an extremely
controversial and original thinker he
became known in the European tradition
because he was a great doctor and he
left many medical works a huge medical
encyclopedia so that the Latin Europeans
coleus tradition refers to him as
Rossi's are haz as Roz's it was very
well known that's one name and among the
East my Ealy's so his Malee's are a
particular kind of shears among the is
my ILI's the name that i'm going to be
focusing on is a persian scholar he's a
century later a thousand and fourteen
1088 and his name is nathalie who straw
nasty who so he was also a great poet
and it was a traveler is a very restless
fellow wandered the whole of the islamic
world also went to india he was
converted to these smiley doctrines in
cairo at the time that cairo was a Shia
bastion under the Fatimids
and he is a very eloquent articulate
exponent of a particular strand of this
smiley world in particular he engaged
with the thought of it ah see so we have
Abdullah bacha bazi
and nastily who stroke and as angry
Colburn was the great Aslam assist
specialist in this area he correctly
said the
position between Roz's and the Smiley's
is one of the great moments in Islamic
thought other scholars have also noted
this intimate link between the city of
copper and odd or conflicting
temporalities marina Warren in her book
on the Arabian Nights
nice book she states correctly that the
caravan winding its way through the
desert is moving backward through time
to the time of the long-dead who can
nevertheless still speak to us through
the inscriptions they left behind and
abdel fattah cholito that's another name
I warmly recommend to remember Abdel
Fattah culito he's a kind of he's a
scholar for sure also a writer he's
Moroccan publishes in Arabic and in
French two or three of his books have
been published in English is a wonderful
wonderful scholar certainly one of the
most insightful of the modern scholars
of the nights he says in a beautiful
essay that the story offers us two
distinct temporal modes first we enter a
kind of eternal present the time of the
gene who emerged from the copper bottles
in which Solomon had imprisoned them and
who called out as if Solomon were still
there to hear them at daba daba
I repent I will never disobey again
these jinn have no awareness of pastime
or of death they live in a kind of
eternal tortuous present but secondly
there's the deep past of the lost city
perfectly preserved whose dead people
including their Queen tadmor call out to
us from a terrible even infinite
distance very much as the storyteller
himself or herself so often does and
these two times says gallito are
literally incommensurable you cannot
measure them one against the other
that's a good thought I think there's
a way to deepen it maybe but becoming
back to that in a moment richer I want
you to think again of those poetic
inscriptions that may well be the oldest
stratum of the story the seed around
which the narrative slowly budded and
grew who is the real author or authors
of these poetic texts warning us over
and over of what happened long ago and
what will surely soon overtake us as
well and perhaps it has already
overtaken us our lives like those of the
dead souls in the city are from the
moment of our birth heavy with time or
with time fulness yet we also experience
time in the fleeting present moment as
did the authors of those texts and the
coffeehouse narrator singers who must
have composed them in some kind of
extended present moment or moments
sometimes I think those inscriptions
were composed by time itself a living
conscious being that's a lousy time
itself caught up in continuous movement
between its two contrary inner rhythms
the rapid uneven pace of Evanescence and
the slow but steady drip of eternity may
be both these rhythms are active at any
given moment time speaks to us in its
own voice in these texts repent it is
not yet too late for you though it is
always too late for me that's the true
voice of time time is never on time
but I think we can do better than that
it's a strange haunting message I'm
talking about the inscriptions we get to
hear it over and over one could say the
tense time with its linear sequential
divisions into past present and future
is confronted in our story with tenths
less time an eternity that is
experienced as a frozen and discordant
present moment the travelers to the city
stand face to face with that deadly
eternity itself a kind of ultimate
transience so I want to explore that
conference
and briefly and I'm going to give you
this is going to be a short digression
maybe ten minutes or so about the
debates on time and eternity and life
and death and a little bit about God in
the soul that occupied the best minds of
Horace on in Baghdad in the 9th to 11th
centuries and I'm going to try to point
out a little later of course what is at
stake and to see what parts of it
irrelevant to our story so this is 10
minutes of the a kind of executive
summary of 300 years of very intense for
this optical debate much of it centering
on these questions of the time suppose
that time is something real power or a
force maybe a thing
maybe an imagined thing that's what NASA
daeho's Rodya smiley philosopher says he
says time is something that human beings
imagine which by the way doesn't mean
that it's not real or maybe time is a
living substance something that we
encounter under two complementary but
also contradictory aspects both of them
independent of God that's Abubakar
arrazi time exists or rather moves both
in the guise of wholeness or perfection
and in the more transparent guise of
sequence of discrete units or parts
leaves all parts that can never
constitute a whole that first sequence
less immeasurable time is called his
names it's called özil or Abid or muda
muda means sheer duration or Sarmad or
daher which also means faith or zaman
mutlaq that means absolute time and
ordinary time which is time that is
measured as Aristotle said by the
movement of the heavenly bodies
is called Zaman this time or is a man
masseur or wacked Mayan that is a
defined moment or deafhope which is a
kind of second and it's not hard to hear
it's continuous rhythm tough tough tough
didn't if you look at the handout from
yesterday I want to read you what abu
bakr r.a zi said about this if you look
those of you who have the handout look
at the bottom of the page and i'm just
going to read you a few lines this is
from a conversation that was recorded by
an interlocutor who did not agree at all
with m abu bakr r.a C in fact regarded
him as a kind of a heretic but was
interested in him and his name the
interlocutor
is also a Razzie Abu haughty Marathi I
told you there are a lot of are Aziz so
all we have is the record of this
conversation by the interlocutor Abu
hottie Marazzi and he says he speaks
first and then he records the answer he
says I said that me have the real
meaning of absolute time so that we
shall be able to imagine it for if we
withdraw the celestial motions the
passing of days and nights and the
elapsing of hours from our imagination
time is then annulled in the imagination
so that we do not know it's real sense
so locate for me the motion of Dada
immeasurable duration that you assert to
be absolute time he said this is Abu
Bakr al Aziz
he said you not see how the being of
this world elapses with the passing of
time of stuff it absolute time does not
come to an end and does not vanish the
same is true of the motion of doubt if
you imagine at
time you notice he also speaking about
an imaginative act time he says as an
imaginative perception and as you can I
given you only a little part of this
conversation if you read further becomes
very clear that he thinks a lousy it
absolute time this mood you know sheer
duration is also moving it's not as it's
not a static entity it's in motion and
you can hear it if your ear is attuned
to it tough tough tough I was thinking
maybe we should just be silent for a few
seconds you can see if you can hear it
the passage of eternity okay so how do
these two temporalities relate to one
another this is a big question
both are aspects or rhythms of time is
it possible that eternal time gives
birth from within itself to everyday
time and if so was there a temporal
moment when this transition took place
when time began to run more quickly
racing toward the death that awaits
every living being that's what these
many philosophers thought they thought
there was a certain moment when our kind
of time emerged out of or was created
from within this other pre-existing
absolute time so there's a moment when
eternity turns into Evanescence
interestingly the Ismaili philosophers
insist that the transition was
instantaneous this caught my attention
I've been reading Nathalie who through
for some months it's an amazing thing he
insists that there is no gap whatsoever
between this absolute time and then
suddenly the you know this time of our
everyday experience so it makes you
wonder why that's so important anyway at
a particular point that was actually not
a point time happened so to speak I'm
following the Ismaili line of argument
so on the one hand there never was and
could not be any gap between eternal
time and our time God didn't just wait
for the right moment to start the clock
and in any case he could not God forbid
have been late or maybe even too late as
an expression for that in persian tahi
Ricard so could there be a subtle delay
inside god no there cannot be on the
other hand human beings as we know do
tend to be late in fact this may be what
defines us as beings and these maladies
have a way of describing this they have
a kind of myths of origin so I'm going
to just tell you a little tiny piece of
this myth okay but you'll see how that
notion of being a little late is very
critical there's the very first man he's
called Aladdin Maru Hani the spiritual
Adam so actually he was a kind of
angelic being and the third in a series
of emanations well that's just so that
you know what I'm talking about
there's God there's an emanation which
is a kata that is intellect and kind of
universal intellect that's then followed
by another emanation of what is called
nufs nafs is the breath of life or the
spirit or maybe the soul those are the
first two and then this atom rouhani is
born the first human being he's number
three but the fascinating thing is that
he was driven by despair and self-doubt
to a critical existential hesitation
that took some time some say that he saw
the entire universe as actually nothing
and no thing and this perception led to
a melancholy stupor from which he
eventually tore himself free a little
too late or maybe the problem was a kind
of pride in self inflation in which case
this human creature has an affinity with
the Satanic
of Iblees you should keep this in mind
those of you who saw the film yesterday
you remember at the very beginning of
the film Shakib this kind of kooky
mystique he has a whole story about
eglise when he calls Emily's in any case
by the time this person this first human
being regained control of himself seven
other angels had interposed themselves
between him and God so he'd been demoted
from the third angel to the tenth and a
rather big gap had opened up and that is
who we are we are creatures of the gap
we were they say created and brought to
life within that gap this belated moment
has a name it's called Tahoe or tal oof
that's an infinitesimal late coming
which is also a moment of turning toward
God Latif at the act of the soul or
breath the nufs that awakens to its
entanglement in the world of forms and
pleasures and seeks to return to its
true home but all this takes time a time
that is once again a kind of no time a
singular simultaneous instant in which
eternal duration turns into its opposite
sequential rapidly flowing ultimately
and universally lethal time so I'm not
going to be able to describe the details
of this transition it's a complex
mythological portrait they're very
interesting and precise I just want to
say that in this view time all of time
it has within it a constant tension
between movement and quiescence in
Persian room bandha and our Amira or an
Arabic they talk of the two phases of
time one that is metallic in motion and
the other sacking dwelling resting
remaining and that tension is what
constitutes the rhythmic movement of
time as we know it it's something in us
just as we are trapped within it like in
one of those copper caskets with the
gene what is more that tension shapes
every one of our moments
so here I I just want to tell you in the
mature column that is to say the
Orthodox synthesis the Islamic
philosophy they have a notion of what
they call the a gnat that means nows in
the plural the nose the nose are these
little instance and you know the amazing
thing this became the Orthodox Islamic
view the amazing idea is that Allah
creates the world anew every single
instant
every moment every one of those little
now moments and those are called a gnat
in the plural the nose you know so I
mean obviously there's a problem here
about what actually that means what
these nowas are what what is this what
kind of time is this the present it's
always the hardest of all temporal modes
to define and and usually paradoxical no
matter how you look at it because the
present is the fullest expression of
that tencel but also creative relation
there's a great Disraeli Arabist [ __ ]
penis he is by the way the person who in
a way mediated the work of Paul Krauss
whom I mentioned yesterday the person
who had collected the fragments of
Aurora Rossi
eNOS wrote a amazing book about
atomistic viewers and he says this is
penis speaking he says the closer one
looks at the alleged substance of time
the more the latter reduces to an
instant for whatever his past has become
nothing in the future does not yet exist
it's the end of the quote so the only
real temporality would thus be that is
elusive present instant that however has
the potential to expand to include all
other forms of time but the Smiley's
also say that present nurse is only a
sign or a mark
ishani or a trace delineating past from
the future
so the present moment is the trace that
opens up infinity in relation to itself
and that mark or trace has weighted down
with time an infinite yet transient time
so interesting isn't it that transience
and infinity or eternity keep somehow
coming together in me in relation to the
present moment
and also in relation to our story that's
the end of this 10 minute executive
summary I want you to stay with me for
just one moment more this is a South
Asian Indian aspect to this you see that
the present moment can open up to absorb
all other kinds of time a range of
rhythms at odds with each other would
have pleased the great 5th century
Indian philosopher of language Bartra
Hari he too thinks of an unlimited
present nacelle other fleeting realities
may emerge that unitary temporality
generates from within itself were within
language as sound a mostly illusionary
temporal sequence an object this is
barter Hari an object any object is past
present and future all at once in
identity these distinctions he says are
in reality no more than different
designations and I think that Bartra
Hari directly or indirectly left his
mark on the Islamic philosophers of time
and ultimately on the city of copper
this is one part of the Indian Indian
stratum or a substratum that has molded
the story into the form we have so
summing up to this point we have at
least two distinct temporal modes
eternal time and transient time both are
in movement with different velocities
and rhythms they are also continually
weaving themselves into one another
thereby creating a present moment one
the familiar rapid pace of time as we
normally experience it is apparently
derived from the other infinitely slower
rhythm in a paradoxical process deeply
bound up with the emergence of human
beings and their longing to return to
that
original slow temporality actually
present 'no scums from the
superimposition of these two modes on
each other and apparently there's also
something like timeless time and maybe
also deathless death there's a tension
not easily resolved movement and
quiescence wholeness and fragmentation
as if time were in each present moment
oscillating between these poles or as if
the present what we call the present had
a part of itself that is eternal and
another part that continually disappears
into that eternity so what about the
temporality of our story I'll be summing
it up in little while as I draw this
lecture to its close but for now let me
say that the city of copper inhabits and
is ruled by both temporal modes but in a
peculiar way it's as if the cogs of time
had locked together the two modes
cancelling each other out so a third
rhythm had to emerge a present moment
alive only with death frozen in its dead
aliveness trapped inside the gateless
walls of the city like the gene in their
copper vessels almost as if we ourselves
were those gene where perhaps were the
inadvertent spectators and witnesses for
whom the city has been waiting for
centuries maybe for all eternity waiting
to capture us and as visitors we hover
for a moment amazed moved to tears
terrified in that moment which feels
like an eternity listening to the
silence that nonetheless speaks to us in
a dead language translated of course
into Arabic I can't resist quoting here
a single bite a single verse by Kashmiri
poet modern Kashmir poet a gosh I he'd
alley some of you may know the name it's
a beautiful poem called razzle he says
the only language of loss left in the
world is Arabic these words were said to
me in a language not Arabic
but okay I was talking about a third
rhythm and that third rhythm is neither
eternity nor human time but a kind of no
time that might also be the only time
that ultimately counts that is time is
imagined as NASA D justo says and it is
real because it is imagined that no time
the kind of present claims several
victims but those who survived to
continue the journey are forever changed
not like the gene with their
anachronistic cry of at Alba and not
like the Sufis who have prepared
themselves well for this journey but in
some deeply human way that even we the
listeners can perceive and moreover I
want to quote NASA D who throw again he
says the whole purpose of the world is
in humanity as distinct from the
individual man or woman who is mortal
and one could also translate the
sentence the world becomes complete or
whole or perfect through the human what
sort of human the sort who lives in that
no time which is a kind of eerie
double-faced present well if there were
more time I could do some other really
fascinating things about the way these
she of philosophers went with these
materials but I want to go back to the
Indian substrate him that I mentioned
before in its modern version so I'll get
a little relief from the philosophy now
I'm going to talk about the Tamil
version of this story that I mentioned
yesterday Tamil prose version remember I
told you that this version miraculously
reemerged from a long forgetfulness the
author imam Alerus apologizes in his
introduction to the reader for the
faculties translated the verses these
beautiful verses into prose so I think
this is the right moment for that little
experiment that I promised you yesterday
and here's here's what I want to do
first of all I should just I'll explain
in just a second
to say that the Tamil text of Imam Allah
truce it's full of vocabulary taken from
Persian and Arabic sources also filled
with Sanskrit in Tamil terms some of it
residents of the party devotional
traditions some of it from Tamil tantric
thought and a lot of it relates to time
he talks about Colavito the contrary
movement of time or against time and
calleb Haida the constant diffusion of
time into very tiny units but what I
want to do is I want you to hear how one
of those morbid inscriptions will take
the first one that I read yesterday how
it sounds in Tamil prose but first I'm
going to read it again in Arabic because
my feeling is that even if you don't
know Arabic or Tamil there should be
something in the sheer sonic or sonic
expressive force that gives you some
sense of the texture of these two
different texts even though they're
telling the same story and not only the
same story but actually translating the
same supposedly lost Greek inscription
so let's see I'll read you the English
translation first and then the Arabic
again and then you'll hear it in Tamil
Tamil prose so an Arabic oh sorry in
English a people they made things then
wept for the wealth they relinquished a
fortress inside it the last word about
rich Lords meeting in the dust
yes finished them off toward them
asunder they lost to the dust whatever
they had gathered as if for no more than
a moment they'd laid down their loads to
take rest then of a sudden moved on you
heard that yesterday and this is one of
those inscriptions that as soon as it's
translated into Arabic Emir Musa breaks
down and weeps and faints and so on so
in Arabic home you enter ahoo bad
Mehsana oh yeah ba la mochila Venus all
philosophy he muntaha haben unseren
viterbi Kazumi Oh
a bad who moutain Barack to whom what
dial will toward image mo kanima holla
holla mo yesterday who for certain haha
ok you want to hear it in Tamil okay
this Tamil pros are in the victor part
of our hell week to chill do marry angle
a about Xavier Perry part of our hull a
battle shade the Pentagon now in the
vagal a miracle it about helical repeat
by avid sorry Papa hahaha Erik in drona
Oh
in the Vaseline Indra he para like on
Gavin a he Malachi L so he tearin' de
verga lipo meal very cool cut and cut a
mighty kneecap activator in the cold
Pony Rabbani una carrera de da da da da
da
our Hal Sahara Maha bandha Condit under
ha ha ha Lamar Anna Marie to be to the
Iman IV d'Ivoire Halle had to depart to
meet her
sounds a little differently
so this is what it means in English
translated into an English prose like
Tamil Oh traces left by those who are
destroyed it's an apostrophe to these
traces Oh traces left by those who are
destroyed what sort of people were they
what works did they do all such things
their signs meant to bring knowledge to
those who come in a later time o you who
stand at this gauge and see this song
you know interestingly you have to see
this on if you can't hear this song it's
an inscription you're about to learn how
all those who lived happily in this
palace have been stuffed one gob after
another into the belly of the earth here
is what you are to know together they
lived it up and then death destroyed
them they left behind this palace they
were driven far away
a lot of this a lot of the expressive
forests in both of the text rests upon
the verbs which are mostly passive the
very pronounced in the Tamil it's a
little unusual in Tamil this is a
slightly antiquated 19th century mid
19th century Tamil prose remember I told
you it's perhaps the first time a
literary prose that we have once these
people were happy the next thing you
know they were stuffed into the belly of
the earth and they left only traces on
the Allen gal addressed as if alive and
aware by the anonymous writer of the
inscription himself tell us who they
were what they did what happened to them
and in a slight recursive reflexive
twist the author's voice mingles with
that of the pig refers who the pig Rufus
the author who exactly is writing this
lament a certain knowledge is at stake
read on a reader I pity you for what you
are assumed to know sounds like the
author of the story the storyteller
sometimes the tamil takes off in a
lyrical figured image of its own this is
something unique to the Tamil so here's
a little tiny passage Aamir Moussa and
Sheikh Abdul Samad they looked keen
keenly for a long time at the fortress
like walls of the palace and the longer
they looked the more it seemed to them
that those walls were weeping
incessantly without tears and as if and
as if they were howling and screaming
without having experienced any kind of
sorrow whatsoever as if they were
singing a lament Oh party remembering
those who had lived here happily and
then died and disappeared and lament
Aparri it's a very well known Tamil
genre it's used in funeral dirges and
rituals for the dead there's a good book
about it by a dear colleague of ours
her name is Isabel Clarke desist she
died in a kind of accident just about a
year ago just very young a book is
called no one cries for the day
tamil dirges rowdy songs and graveyard
petitions so Oh Perry this is lament and
the howling walls comprise a figure of
speech it's called boot apprecia in
tamil it's called pat Cody petrm that is
classically a description of some
feature from one domain to something or
someone from another domain and very
often this is the projection of
intentionality and feeling onto an
inanimate object like the walls of a
city and there's an onomatopoeic aspect
the long sentence Aveda - metahuman
ababa commonly related to cattle cattle
over the pole oven you can hear the howl
relate the lie you did and beyond all
this there's a paradox tearless steers a
scream with no trigger but for the
unremembered memory that we hear about
it at the end
anyone who knows tamil poetry feels at
home with this sentence this is a South
Indian sentence it seems perfectly
capable of reflecting back upon the
Arabic or Persian source illuminating it
and in fact once you've read the
sentence you'll hear that howl
whenever you reread the Arabic version
of the nights indeed all of the
inscriptions and perhaps the story as a
whole in its various versions have
become a lyrical unending heart-rending
lament the very stuff of sequence and
the texture of movement through time and
as I've stressed all of them are in
prose I want to say something more about
prose both this experimental early Tamil
kind and maybe prose in general prose
perhaps contrary to our intuition as I
said yesterday is always a discovery or
an invention or some combination of
these two it differs from metrical verse
not merely formally but more importantly
in the way it's the internal
organization its syntax relates to some
version of reality that's the hour
thisis that syntax always mimics the way
the world is put together
mentally but for my purposes tonight the
important point is that prose always
comes with its own rhythms and these
rhythms always reflect in various ways
attention inherent to the temporality
itself very much as we saw earlier at
the very least prose embodies a
disparity or discrepancy between two
temporal modes tense time whether or not
it is morphologically signaled modal or
aspectual was simplistically sequential
and a hrithik amove Madrid mikhyl
movement of time that cannot be squeezed
into any series of tenses and they're
morphs close sentences very often weave
in and out of these two minimal rhythms
especially by the way in revision
languages as speakers of Tamil or Telugu
Malayalam know from experience tense
time is always less than that other time
non tense time has a way of overwhelming
tense time just as our natural
experience of subjective time with its
uneven flow it's fast in congruence of
intensities often overwhelms the
comfortable illusion of Newtonian time
flowing in even units without gaps
that's one kind of Newtonian time and
some have claimed like a colleague of
mine in Jerusalem Gaby Motzkin that the
clash of these two temporalities
personal time is experienced moment by
moment and sometimes recorded in Diaries
and impersonal objective time that clash
is what gives birth to modern
historiography because history in order
to write history you need at least two
incompatible temporalities and it is not
by chance as Motzkin argues that modern
Western European historiography comes
into being in prose in tandem with the
French diarists like Sen Simone in the
first half of the 18th century prose
historiography and I might add the
concept of realism
are all facets of the same problem and
all belong in a way to the same
historical moment
so I won't have time to explore this
theme tonight with the attention it
deserves but let me just say first that
prose is thick with time and in some
sense it's about time or better in
bodies time and second that prose
regularly offers the reader or listener
a selection of diverse temporalities
which also embody differential
causalities held together as our buffs
are clearly by the illusion of linear
syntax and it's an old idea by the way
this goes back as far as to acidities
the illusion of linear syntax because a
prose sentence is a kind of useful
delicious solution probably generated by
that same unresolved tension in time
that I've been speaking about I don't
know what reality is but I know for sure
that it is far more jagged uneven and
unfinished than a good prose sentence
poetry works differently on the mind
and on our sense of the real there are
complex modal forms in South Indian
languages especially as if
counterfactual statements that
hypertrophy both in everyday speech and
in more elegant literary prose more so
than in poetry and thirdly I think it's
not quite by chance that imam al aru's
chose to play with the possibilities of
prose through this compelling story the
city of copper which is in itself this
is my argument a brilliant meditation on
the confusing but ever-present rhythms
of time in fact I would say that Imam
Alerus
simit Isis that same tensile temporal
and causal allusion that lies at the
heart of our story so before I close I
want to take a couple of minutes to talk
about the film that many of you saw
yesterday
Oliver lashes remarkable film new Moses
and as I've already hinted I think this
baffling and rather breathtaking film is
an unconscious probably unconscious
modern version of the city of copper it
has that odd simultaneous temporal flow
in at least two contrasting rhythms also
some awareness of the tantalizing gap or
break-in time that I've been speaking
about
there's the agonizingly slow movement of
the caravan through the mountains it's a
kind of eternity I've now seen this film
I guess five times and not sure I can
bear to see it another time because it's
so it's the only 90 minutes but it feels
like forever that that movement through
the mountains and that kind of a Trinity
also interestingly is the time of dreams
and visions and riddles and divination
failed divination I think that's
important and that the film sheds light
on the story because of that and when
the journey ends when eternity is
finished the mad heroes die and then
there is the odd modern rush of cars
through the desert as if without any
real goal or purpose everyday time the
two rhythms converge in the eccentric
figure of the mystic Shakib he's the one
with the long scraggly hair and the
burning eyes whose task it is to make
sure that the caravan finds the city of
copper scg Lhasa is even called dune his
daughter has told us right from the
start we can see that Shakib is more
than slightly mad
he's drunk on God or on truth we first
meet him telling a story to the drivers
waiting to be called to work a story he
says about Earth about its creation so
what does he say God created Adam from
dust or from clay he called the angels
to bow down to him emily's that is he
bliss Satan he started to bow down
little by little remember he slowly
shows you little by little that slow
movement and at the last moment he
beliefs raised his head and he saw God
breathing the soul
laughs into human beings and since then
he bliss knows the secret of human
beings and he plays with him as he likes
that's what she keeps says the caravan
is accompanying an old chick who wants
to die and be buried with his ancestors
in siege little masa the city of copper
but he dies too soon
early in the journey and the caravan
falls apart only the thief and rogue
Ahmed remember Ahmed is the true hero of
the film and his dark friend Sayid also
a thief are left to carry the corpse
across the mountains to see Jill Massa
Shakib joins them though they see that
he is strange and an old man and his
mute daughter Akram also turn up early
on Ozma despairing says if we continue
through the mountains death will be
certain that's what we want in a second
later he hears the old ship say
independently these same words death is
what we want and Achmed is astonished he
said the same thing I said Shakib knows
things like AB dishonoured in our story
but he knows them in strangely even self
parodic ways he has a charm a bodily
gesture that he says will tell you what
to do when you don't know the way
remember
unfortunately the charm never works
neither does the act of divination that
Achmed resorts to there are two birds on
a mountain and Ahmed says since they
don't know what to do um it says if they
fly home we stay here if they stay we
move on then they wait a minute or two
what happens one bird fly sauce you know
one bird fly it sounds as if God is
strangely silent throughout as this is
habit although the journey itself is
presented to us as a kind of Prayer or
invocation each section three sections
they're named after the bodily movements
kneeling prostrating arising that each
Muslim performs five times each day but
what kind of a prayer is it
there seems to be a riddle unanswerable
somewhere at its heart like the final
riddle that had more bill keys the Queen
of Sheba once posed to Solomon or like
the secret that he believes found out
when God breathed life into the human
being a dimension of absurdity in here's
in the entire progression perhaps we're
seeing the absurdity of faith itself
that's a nice North African thought
think of Tertullian in the second
century at cartridge that the Carthage
Tertullian famously said creo quia
absurdum I believe because it's observed
because it's absurd and all this makes
me wonder if the ironic and parodic
impulse is present although hidden in
our coffeehouse story itself so how did
you think about that and decide for
yourself but in any case the film offers
us that final mad rush to die to die
into the fantasy or illusion in a city
with its seven walls each made of a
different metal it's eight towers it's
14 mountains it's six navigable rivers
flowing into the ocean it's 15 gates and
Ahmed who has slowly matured into a
human being in the course of this
apparently pointless journey but who is
now almost comatose destroyed by its
terrors he rides with Shakib into the
midst of the murderous mob that is
torturing the mute girl he crammed to
death by hanging
you remember Shakib says to him Ahmed he
says Ahmed let us go the time has come
over and over again he says the time has
come
and Ahmed says how will we do it and she
keeps says with love over and over again
he says I hope hope do it with love and
he rushes in Shakib with his toy sword
to save her and at the very last moment
she cries out his name her first and
only word terror opens her mouth and
this image by the way comes from a short
story by the Moroccan author Mohammed
Marat 'but i recommend i owe this
discovery to peg or limb
thank you
so let us continue brother eternity is
waiting for us
that's Shakib again but can eternity
really wait this is Big Time with death
at its core and apparently that fatal
tardiness that marks the start in the
end of little time human time if
eternity is itself the final riddle then
the only answer is the equally opaque
counter riddle of death that third time
or no time that exists when Big Time and
little time or potential time and actual
time mingled with one another in the
city of the Living Dead where time
itself is trapped probably forever in a
sealed copper container just like us
everything is for eternity says Oliver
lash the director and I like that
thought everything is for eternity
there's something comforting in the
sentence and lash also says persuasively
there is nothing unexpected that is not
secretly expected so I'm just going to
take a few moments to sum up I've spoken
about the Arabic text of the city of
copper about its Tamil version about the
film spoken about Abu Bakr arrazi and a
city whose row and the smiley Theo
theologians and believe me we've barely
begun to enter into that unnerving City
but there is something that weaves
together all these diverse tones and
themes common to all the major voices is
an often non-explicit idea of timeless
time or deathless death a voiceless void
and of the great cognitive riddle that
stems from this set of apparent
paradoxes it is by no means certain that
knowledge even divinely sanctioned
knowledge can resolve them we might add
to them the doorway without a doorkeeper
that we know from the city of copper
that doorway already filled with death
leads in both directions inward to Azal
or Daha or muda that is absolute time
outward to the man Dafa walked more iron
every day time I think it's helpful to
think of that doorway is holding in
itself the creative instant where we
also inevitably find the time lag that
is the hesitation the fatal delay which
are denied and the necessary but often
obscured traces and signs which are
affirmed it is that deeply ingrained
paradox that has given us the city of
Cochran times as necessary whose rule
can only be understood by humans as
imagined and that is because he says the
human soul is tied to a body it is under
the sway of time time is the life of a
thing
this is nathalie who stole time is the
life of a thing whose life comes to it
from another unlike the aliveness of
something or someone living through its
own nature and interestingly the human
being shares both of these definitions
he says they hold to that man's essence
is eternal that his continuous sorry
that is his continuance is without end
but his existence is not without a
beginning
note that eloquent double negative
intelligence occupied by definition
eternal it's equivalent to doubt of the
big beginningless time
human beings have aku and they also have
nufs the living spirit breath which
though intimately associated with little
time the time of experience is also
without end as others have said before
me the city of copper is a journey into
time into the depths of time with the
creative instant that almost
non-existent imperceptible gap can be
experienced if one follows the traces
and markers left along the way I don't
think the journey has a goal this
journey is as we know saturated with
death and the still living traces of the
dead
it also enacts the movement from
potential to the actual that most human
of temporal modes and that movement is
equivalent to the turning the NAAFS take
stored form and substance including I
suppose a good story but all the signs
and traces we encounter in our story
frozen in a dead language exhort the
reader to the opposite turning from
mortal form and substance back to the
true source the principle of a timeless
aliveness probably that slight instant
of turning always faces both ways and
like thought itself tends toward the
tardy the secondary reflection the less
than lucid inside whether we think in
terms of a temporal duality like arrazi
or remain with a synthetic vision of
NASA t who's throwing his followers it
appears that time itself always precedes
the birth of time
which is a devolved even the based
version of itself within time there must
be attention an expectancy as if time
awaits the interruption of its natural
rhythm and it's impregnation by the nufs
a passing moment moment chosen by God so
that our kind of time can begin just a
little late in the story death is
ultimate transience the very essence of
evanescent everyday time which comes to
an end for each individual as the text
keeps telling us transience is true time
slips away from us and death is real but
death apparently can also subsist within
life and vice versa
we are surrounded by the Living Dead
also by the still living traces of their
lives which are capable of speaking to
us with a burning though anachronistic
urgency the inscriptions are the signals
deposited in time the trace left by
action or perhaps as I've suggested they
might be the dissonant voices of time
itself no less trapped in this world
than we are
depths of time reveal as one approaches
them the coincidence of the two or
perhaps three primary rhythms we have
explored both are at work in the present
instant it is both fleeting we can
always hear that tough tough tough
and oddly eternal holding all of time
and world incited that coincidence
hardly makes sense unless we think of it
as the unending movement of potentiality
into actuality because the actual will
always lag behind the potential and is
doomed to being late indeed too late
such a movement will never be fully in
sync with God's own time and will always
leave behind a slight gap a trace like
the city of the Living Dead like the
book that speaks for it's vanishing
author can we ever see past that gap or
that haunting trace do they really exist
do they both exist and not exist his
death also a gap at once riddled with
time fulness and utterly empty of time
these are the questions that lead one to
the city of copper or perhaps like Emir
Musa at the end of his life to Jerusalem
where appearances to the contrary
notwithstanding there still may be a
chance to discover to know even to
understand deathless death space without
space and time this time thank you very
much
[Applause]
all right yeah
to be
I thank you so much for this amazing
lecture so I was thinking about the
movie and I have a theory the theory is
that our is shake the one who is going
to help these other the caravel he might
be I thought to myself maybe an angel
the boss he seems to know everything
about the situation oh this Caravan you
know you have to protect them because
their leader is gonna die and and then
he's he has this naivety that we
sometimes associate with angels angels
are so important for Muslims for him for
Christians I think there's this I don't
know I felt maybe I I was thinking about
this other movie of beam vendors that
him an overbearing the one if was
translated as winds of desire I think in
the US this angels are they're kind of
listening to us crying or having
problems but they cannot do much they
feel so frustrated and I felt that with
with the figure of this mystic who is
they're trying to help them but cannot
do much I don't know what you think
about these thoughts also the idea of
the the taxi drivers though they were
almost like this angels trying to get
their souls really allowed thank you did
I I think that's Shakib this is Shakib
he yeah he's got the innocence of an
angel that's true
and of course he's very weird and
there's something ridiculous about him
over and over again I mean he talks
about faith and he's praying all the
time he says everything he does
everything is but actually none of it
ever seems to work and it's possible to
read the end of the film where he comes
dashing into this you know maybe this is
all happening somewhere in the recesses
of his mind you know I mean it kind of
looks like that
I think of him though in relation to
this story that I mean this is obviously
it's not kind of complete so it's not a
carbon copy of the city of copper it's
it's something that is somehow absorbed
those materials have done something new
with him I think of him as being like up
the summit this wise old man who is the
one who's able to decipher all of the
descriptions and somehow gets them you
know it gets them to the end and we
don't know what happens to him at the
end right just as we don't know with
Shakib yeah
to ask a question I'm I'm struck time
and the and the discrepancy between the
two modes of time that you've been
talking about is the product in in some
of these views of the human imagination
and and yet and yet it seems to me or
involves the human imagination in some
way and yet it seems to me that it also
poses the limitations of that
imagination the failure of that omission
the imagination almost and what I was
thinking about and at moments in your
talk was the the the commensurability
between the views that you're talking
about here and two other instances one
is slightly mundane and I'm thinking
about Fenelon broad Dells historiography
and and and the conjuncture is between
the longer a and and and you know the
froth on the wave of history that is
that is the that is the the momentary
time that you talk about but more
importantly more recently I'm thinking
about Anthropocene writing aphasia
especially de peche Chakravarthi but
other writers as well who are trying to
wrestle with the fact that we cannot
come to grips with the Anthropocene
because the scales of time that read
that are that are involved are are are
are so immense in comparison to the
absolute to the momentary time that we
can imagine that that there simply is a
gap in our imaginary powers to get there
and this was you're reminding me of all
this yeah I think actually the minute we
start thinking about time in any serious
way these incongruities are going to
come up to the fore because obviously I
mean none of us experience time is an
even flow human beings do not think they
may think there is such a thing you know
they're scientists who think like that I
guess although I've been recently
reading a book that these physicists
about the physics of time you know they
tend to think that time is an illusion
altogether but I think that the notion
of a kind of dissonance between one's
own you know live time and some other
dimension of time is a kind of universal
phenomenon but I do think it's inflected
differently in different cultures
obviously different texts and so on so
here I I think there's a fairly specific
you know in this story I think it comes
out of an attempt to as it were enact
these incongruities for these different
rhythms and that's the beauty of this
story in a way because these two rhythms
although they're incompatible they're
also embedded in one another so that
you're at not ever able actually just
say you see if it were an allegory
yesterday we're talking about an
allegory so now the glory would say okay
you know we're going to die but there's
an eternal life and we'll go into that
eternal it then will be fine
can pilot a positive and optimistic view
of life but it's nothing like that the
story doesn't leave you with that it's
just the opposite with the sense that
mortal human beings living in time
experience some sense of kind of eternal
dimension and that eternal that eternity
is somehow I do know it odds with their
experience of themselves as mortal and
you know fragile little beings and
there's no real resolution to that I
guess you know that's to my mind one of
the great things in the story it doesn't
leave you with a kind of simple formula
but it does I think articulate the
problem in an amazing way yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
possibility yeah so in a way the city of
Cochran looks like a kind of yoga
Vasishta story I suppose you know the
elements of the elements of that kind of
absurd paradoxical experience are very
present there I don't know why I mean
yoga Vasishta of course not just a
single thing but again and again you're
right there's this notion that we don't
perceive the world we can't see the
world as it is there's a huge illusion
which envelops us at all times but the
amazing thing as Gary Taba said the
amazing thing in the yoga vasishta is
that it doesn't recommend that we wake
up from this illusion into some kind of
saying you know sober perception but
rather wants us to wake up into the
illusion thereby reinforcing it so I
don't know that there's anything like
that in these materials that I've been
talking about but it's a good example of
course the
yoga vasishta of the same kind of
problematic that you know once you begin
thinking about what lives experience is
in relation to other kinds of time thank
you
I guess my question is in the story in
the city copper there's like all these
references to to God God being beyond
time hmm the big question is is God in
this thinking was a kind of eternal mode
of time or is or is God timeless time
and is there some kind of
differentiation between these two yeah
so that's one of these questions that
were bones of contention between
arrazi and the east my ILI's because
they are Ossie this was one of the one
of the points that caused him to be
considered heretical and to be
excommunicated by a later generation
NASA D who Stroh where I keep quoting
thought of arrazi as as a heretic why
was that that was because among other
things because he thought that time
precedes God and exists independently of
God it has its own nature that nature is
a double nature that kind of you know
absolute time and and in condition time
and so on but nonetheless it exists in
the world along with various other
things like God like space like matter
like the soul those are the elements
that are all there from the beginning
and they're independent of God's
intentionality or will the smileys don't
like that idea you can see why they
would not so they want to have an
orderly sequence in which there is God
who has a kind of timelessness in time
right the embodies this timelessness and
then there's a transition of which to in
which God is somehow complicit or
involved from that eternal mode into the
mode of human time or everyday time or
something like that now if your question
is what about this story where does it
positions itself I think it positions
itself very much in the seam line
between these two positions giving a
kind of articulation to both of them and
the city of copper is kind of a place
like that if you think about it see I
mean on the one hand these people are
there they're looking straight at it at
eternity that's just right this is a
kind of seemingly motionless time but on
the other hand that that's the time of
transience and death everything is
passed away the inscriptions keep
telling us over and over again you know
so what kind of eternity is it is as if
eternity itself was evanescent no
something like that
so that's I think a rather amazing thud
and it's a thought that sort of
naturally emerges out of this kind of
story you know and that's why it resists
the allegorical impulse you know it
resists it because the complexity of its
understanding of time has to allow for
this kind of paradoxical oscillation
between two different poles
they forgot an Arabic but many folktales
there's the formula right it's like can
something God makan but but in terms of
the language of if you were to go to a
kind of prop in analysis like does the
language itself create this you know
this mythic time certain formulas yeah
mr. acidic teach each language hey yeah
is that that's the question which yeah I
think I forgot an herb that could
something like you know kana see that's
the grip of being so but that's what
Allah says when he brings the world into
existence he says cool be be yeah so
yeah it could be I mean I I'm
sympathetic to the notion that the
Arabic version of the story it has
within it already embedded in the
language certain temporal notions that
are not explicit
[Applause]
[Music]